he was quite literally osama bin laden's
right-hand man the doctor turned
terrorist who became leader of al-qaeda
when bin laden was killed by u.s navy
seals in 2011. his death now is the most
significant counter-terror operation for
the americans since then my fellow
americans
on saturday
at my direction
the united states successfully concluded
an airstrike in kabul afghanistan that
killed the emir of al-qaeda
el zawiri
he'd been a wanted man since the late
1990s a 25 million dollar bounty on his
head
in the end remarkably he was tracked
down to a safe house linked to the
taliban in the afghan capital kabul u.s
officials say intelligence located his
wife and children to a building in the
city for months they monitored it and
spotted zawahiri we're told the
president was briefed last month and
informed that the al qaeda leader had
been seen repeatedly in the house he
never left the building but was often
out on the balcony last week the
president gave the green light for a
strike and shortly after 6am kabul time
on sunday two hellfire missiles were
fired from a drone
he played a key role a key role in the
bombing of u.s embassies in kenya and
tanzania killing 224
and wounding over 4500 others
he carved a trail of murder and violence
against american citizens
[Music]
and then there was 9 11 planned and
carried out with such devastation on the
orders of bin laden and zawahiri
he was an egyptian jailed in cairo with
other islamists in the 1980s
he became the brains of al qaeda the
guiding figure behind the public face
that was bin laden the americans are
claiming a great victory with his
killing president biden proving he says
that america doesn't need to be in
afghanistan to kill terrorists there no
matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people the
united states will find you and take you
out
in the uk reaction from the mi6 chief
tough job professionally done by our
allies culmination of a long shared
effort since 9 11 to eliminate the
threat posed by zawahiri a man
responsible with his toxic creed for the
death of so many these past three
decades
thoughts with their families tonight but
here's the troubling reality for the
americans they have left afghanistan to
taliban leaders still happy and able to
harbor al-qaeda's leaders that's hardly
reassuring mark stone sky news in
washington